[MUSIC PLAYING]
FATIMA: Hello.
I'm Fatima [INAUDIBLE],, a system
engineer with the Google Cloud
Cortex team.
And if you're interested in
learning about the Cortex
Application Layer, then
this video is for you.
The Cortex Application Layer can
be used as a blueprint for you
to view the distributed
and scalable
applications to securely
consume information
from the Cortex Data Foundation
content residing in BigQuery,
our scalable data
cloud warehouse.
It is composed of the
following services
and provides you a blueprint
to get started quickly.
An event-driven
architecture using Pub/Sub;
an event source--
this is usually your
system of record.
For demonstration, we are using
Cloud Scheduler; a controller
service--
in this case, an inventory
to query inventory levels;
a data access layer that will
securely access BigQuery;
an output service to publish
the results for your query
to Pub/Sub.
The blueprint
provided allows you
to easily add
other microservices
with additional functionality
and reuse the secure data
access and output
patterns created.
For example, you could
use a synchronous call
to complement master
data when creating it
in the system of record, like
SAP, or publish a message
about new stock requirements
for your different
demanding planning systems
to subscribe and consume.
You can deploy the Cortex
Application Layer sample
content from the Marketplace.
For quick access, navigate
through the Cortex App
through the link on the screen.
Now let's see this in action.
First, we navigate to
the Marketplace page.
However, before
the point, you need
to complete the setup
instructions outlined
on the Deployment
Instructions Guide.
This guide has the
comprehensive steps
to configure your environment.
At the end of this guide,
you have all the information
you need in order to
deploy the application
content in your project.
I have already
completed these steps
and this is the output of the
last step in the compilation.
We are ready to deploy.
Let's go ahead and
click on Configure
and start populating our fields
with the correct parameters.
Simply copy the fields
in the correct place.
For the reporting
data set, this should
be the name of the data set
where you deployed the Cortex
data formation models,
which in this example
is the same project with
the name UnicornReporting.
Complete the remaining fields.
When ready, click Deploy.
At this stage, the application
is creating the components
we saw in the diagram earlier.
In addition, as part
of the deployments,
the sample code for
this application
is added to the cloud
source repository for you
to browse and modify.
Check the Readme for a detailed
breakdown of components
and best practices.
You now have a blueprint on
how to consume Cortex Data
Foundation insights from
your downstream business
applications deployed
on your project.
Learn more by clicking on the
link in the description below.
Enjoy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]